fumio kishida arrived in new delhi for
his first visit to india as japanese
prime minister he held talks with
narendra modi the leaders finalized
agreements on cyber security and
sustainable development with japan
announcing 42 billion dollars worth of
investments in india
and while they spoke of their shared
democratic values only the japanese
leader mentioned the russian invasion of
ukraine
the russian invasion of ukraine is a
grave incident shaking the very essence
of the international order we must
respond in a firm and resolute manner i
conveyed such thoughts again to prime
minister modi
prime minister modi focused instead on
the asia pacific alluding to india and
japan's shared concerns about china's
growing influence in the region
india has abstained from voting on
resolutions condemning russia at the
united nations moscow is india's largest
arms supplier and increasingly oil
india's oil imports from russia so far
this month are four times the amount
compared to march last year indian media
is reporting the biggest oil company
here has finalized a deal to buy three
million barrels of oil from russia at a
discounted rate as the u.s and other
countries impose sanctions on moscow
russia has been offering oil and other
commodities to india and other importers
at low prices
the us said india would not be violating
u.s sanctions by purchasing russian oil
but added that such a move would put
india on what it called the wrong side
of history
what we would project or convey to any
leader around the world is that
the world the rest of the world is
watching where you're going to stand as
it relates to this conflict whether it's
support for russia
in any form as they are illegally
invading ukraine
but political analysts say japan is less
likely to be critical of india's towns
in statecraft it's about what what hurts
you most i think china does hurt india
russia doesn't hurt india russia
actually stands by india so i think at
the end of the day it boils down to
national interest and i think these
countries do understand japan most
importantly if not maybe less the less
the other countries but definitely i
think tokyo is in full appreciation of
india's flight in this particular case
unlike statements from the u.s and uk
focusing on india's stand on russia the
japanese prime minister said the two
countries will keep trying to end the
war and keep providing support to
ukraine and its neighboring countries
elizabeth paranam al jazeera new delhi